okay so I pitched this idea to Mariah
you're standing right there well I come
say hi come say hi
come over here say rice says hello
what's up come sit down on hold on a
second okay here we go I think okay now
we have to refocus the camera maybe
hopefully okay hopefully the cameras
refocus okay I pitched this idea to
Mariah Mariah said that I should be on
Team the team from wobble that makes
these movies Avengers in game the
biggest problem movie has okay here's
the biggest problem at a vineyard in
game house is it creates a paradox and
this paradox doesn't really it doesn't
really make a whole lot of sense right
so the way the movie played out was like
this so you had the events of infinity
war we're along over the course of
however long it took them to do it
Dallas capture these Infinity stones and
then with demos finally capture the
Infinity stones he initiated the snap
all right and that wipes out half of
life in the universe that picks up with
the printers in game which as most
people know progresses the way it does
when it's basically an attempt to time
pice the Scotland called it to capture
the Infinity stones we're going back to
the present day and then use them to
undo the snap and it's gonna be as
simple as that right like we bring him
back to the present day we under the
snap then we take him back to the past
Jesus individual locations so they
basically reappear the instant they
vanish so there's no disruption to the
timeline doesn't play out that way
everything that can go wrong will go
right like little like woods it um
Murphy's Law like I think it's Murphy's
Law Murphy's Law Hamlin's razor Occam's
razor Occam's razor is that the simplest
explanation tends to be the best one I
think it's Murphy's Law everything that
can go wrong will go wrong
so because of that it creates paradoxes
note like notably and namely Thanos and
nebula because during the movie
professor Hulk said the timeline can't
be changed right like it's fixed it's
it's absolute you can never change it
all it does is create alternate
realities but they can't go back into
the past
undo something and then it'd have a
ripple effect then which changes the
future and so because of that the if
that's an if that's an absolute
statement and then the way the movie
ends and you guys are right in saying
there is no alternate reality I say
they're living in an alternate reality
but assuming that you guys were are
absolutely right and they're not in an
alternate reality they're still in the
main Marvel Cinematic Universe there's
only one way to make that work now
here's the cool thing about this alright
here's the cool thing about this all
right so honestly I would have done the
second half of the movie completely
different because here's the paradox
that you run into if them if they go
back into the past they start capturing
the Infinity stones and then Thanos
realizes what they're doing and then he
basically travels to the the travels to
like the events of in-game basically
when in game takes place so the
present-day we can call that I'll travel
to the present day and and then like
ultimately he's killed then the question
becomes if Thanos died technically
before he could have captured the
Infinity stones in the first place and
initiated the snap then what reason with
the Avengers have to go back in time and
stop a snap that never happened and so
because that like you run into a paradox
it's like okay they're basically trying
to stop an event that never took place
but they're Charlie into the past which
means the event took place but the event
didn't take place because the guy who
initiated it died before it could happen
so you start running into all these
different problems so slowed eating up
some nebula nebulas past self dies which
begs the question how could she exist in
the future if she was dead in the past
so so what I would have done is I would
have gone back and I would have said
okay so I would have had like the all
the events take place that ran up to
like the final battle right and then it
would have been like okay so like we
killed Thanos surely this fixes
everything
and then like Doctor Strange shows up or
something like that and it's like wrong
answer you know and it's like you guys
screwed up so basically you have like
this this I don't know maybe extra 15
minutes right because movie was already
figured a half hours long anyway what
the hell's 15 minutes gonna do everybody
the credit for that one people were just
sit then yeah yeah they didn't have any
post credit scene so it's not like you
were waiting through all those true for
something particular so what you would
do is or at least what I would do is I
would say okay for that 15 minutes they
keep going into the past and it's like
this is a tip number eight hundred
seventy-two and we went out into space
and we grabbed
tomorrow and we brought her back and she
bought that us early and killed him and
it didn't work like this is attempt
number 926 and we told for aim for the
head and it still didn't work the
timeline still like like the snap still
happened there's no way for us to stop
now and then somebody said like Scott
Lang or somebody makes an offhand remark
and it's like we could just let it play
out and they do like they say okay fine
I won't let that happen so it runs all
the way up and the the one thing cuz
Doctor Strange said an infinity war of
all the different possibilities 14
million some on possibilities only one
world and the only one that worked was
the one where they let Thanos slip
because in every single circumstance
they killed Thanos in every single
timeline they killed Vince right any
world on the line or aim for the head
Captain Marvel showed up and beat him to
death like it only did circumstances
Doctor Strange like kill them whatever
it is like they killed sandals and all
these different alternate realities the
only way they could win and keep the
timeline intact was when I am an
initiated the snap that killed Santos's
forces did he actually just set him back
to the past and like that's it and the
timelines intact everything stays in
time the timeline stays is a regular
timeline there's no paradoxes none of
that stuff I would have stopped I would
not have had nebula killed I would not
have thrown that in there I would have
just said like she was just beaten up
really bad like knocked unconscious by
Gamora or something but I would not have
had like present-day nebula killed past
nebula oh but they basically just sent
that us back to the past because the
only way that I was able to get to the
events of endgame anyway is because they
stole the time travel device they stole
the Pym particles and the time travel
device they could shrink down small
enough to make it you know to get into
the quantum realm and then basically
like grow back in size again and then
unleash all of its forces on the world
so you basically say okay so basically
you go back and and like you send it
back to the past but even if that
happens say for example that like you
don't take away as time travel and you
don't take away the ability for in the
game game Pym particles it doesn't
matter because the timelines still safe
right like it's a loop and it always
plays out the same way it always plays
out the snap happens the Avengers recoup
they go back into the past they steal
the Infinity stones the analyst figures
out what they're doing that owes falls
into the present The Avengers basically
like to send it back to the past and the
day safe every single time and it keeps
a timeline intact it keeps it as a
singular cont
I really should be worthy eventually
just normal ooof a nose state or my
boost a nose yeah Ironman demorgan's yes
but no they they run through 14 million
scenarios like like like what is it like
hella they grab hella hella kills panels
like Serdar kill Stannis all the things
we've wanted to see like all the
whatever questions people have what ifs
or fonts a knows what if hella fought
then let's write like like like new
rockstars has that video where's like
why this annals wait so long but you
literally answer all those questions in
that movie in that time sequence and
like every last one of them fail to say
in the timeline the only one that does
is Ironman same status and it's cool
because it's symbolic in the sense that
it's like hey so like we're Marvel
Studios and we've finally learned our
lesson and we're not killing all the
villains all the time so we can use them
later like like there's nothing
indicating that he's actually still
alive because he I'm saying like I would
have been had I would have done that
like instead of dusting him and killing
him what they did in the movie I would
have ended it so that basically Thanos
lives and like they just send him back
to the past so you can reuse them again
and all that kind of stuff like I mean
you can reuse an in so far is like you
can get him out of the timestream but
technically now he's stuck in a loop
like you'll always feel always travel to
them to the events of any game he'll
always be sent back to the past
so he'll basically never get past the
events opinion he'll be stuck in that
loop for eternity when it puts them on
it puts them on the back burner because
then they can like be like we need fan
else it might just use a time stone
snatch them out of the time loop and
then I would okay tell me you watch them
families versus the Fantastic Four the
New Avengers of the x-men
[Laughter]
yeah that'd be pretty amazing just wreck
them all it would be like our man died
for nothing totally did all that and
then like he is
yeah yeah okay no I meant and I for
anything I'm in died so that he could
his contract could be over this contract
could be ended that's why I amend I
dismiss contract could be done tom no no
Robert Downey jr. dies yes he he died to
save the world saddest point in the
movie The Sands Point in the whole movie
there was nothing was like remove foster
died there was not a dry ice and I'm
surprised you didn't cry I was like I
was like the Indian from the nature
commercials were like they're littering
and I came in turns around once of the
camera like a tear runs down his cheek
like I was that I was that guy like that
was kind of Kaitlyn was crying folks in
the back of the theater were crying when
he died his daughter was just sitting
there watching him like his hologram it
was like just sitting there watching her
dad like oh yeah the last will and
testament of our man bring it back is an
AI that's what I said everyone said oh
yeah yeah Jarvis 2.0 Tony Stark Tony's
anyway guys that's that's that's the
biggest problem that we saw with with in
game and how like it should like really
how it should have been in the way they
kept trying to shoot this guy but
basically understand now there's no
reason to believe it's not an alternate
reality I mean everything that we've
been told the movie basically says that
it is so I don't know but it's kind of
cool but without being said guys we're
gonna wear this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explain miss
you guys at the sub button to become
part of the Rob port you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like a guy do
the fence like and we will catch you all
later peace
[Music]